democrats and 10 republicans vote to
impeach president trump for a second
time
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
says the senate won't take this up
before the inauguration and law
enforcement worries about the weekend
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so it's impeachment two
impeachment two day
impeach harder impeachment two the
empire strikes back
impeachment two this time it's personal
impeachment two too fast too furious
we'll get to impeachment two in just one
second explain all the ramifications
and what exactly is going on because the
media have an interest in
basically assuming that any republican
who didn't vote for impeachment is in
league with the rioters and all of us
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about saving money right
that's something we can all agree on if
we're looking for unity how about saving
money on that cell phone bill you're
spending too much money
on your cell phone bill many americans
say their top new year's resolution is
to save money in the next year well
let's check that box right now when your
family switches to pure talk from at t
verizon or t-mobile you could save over
800 a year
that's real money every single month
right back in your pocket and you don't
have to sacrifice coverage
pure puretalk is on the same network as
one of the big carriers but they charge
you half
that's right no gimmicks no fluff added
to your bills which is why puretalk is
the top rated wireless company by
consumer affairs how about this offer
right now get unlimited talk text and
six gigs of data for just 30 bucks a
month if you go over on data usage
they're not going to charge you for it
so really it's not going to get better
than that
grab that mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do you'll say
off your first month pound two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro
pure talk usa simply smarter wireless
again save a bunch of money on your cell
phone bill get the same coverage you'd
get from any of the big companies except
you're not paying as much money so
really what do you have to lose except a
lot of the bills
they'll just go out the window when you
get pure talk usa tile pound 250
say ben shapiro to get started so
yesterday of course the house
with a little bit of gop support voted
to impeach president trump for the
second time
the total was 232 to 197 222 democrats
unanimous democrat support for
impeachment 10 republicans in favor 197
republicans
against according to the new york times
the house on wednesday impeached
president trump for inciting a violent
insurrection against the united states
government that was the actual charge as
10 members of the president's party
joined democrats to charge him with high
crimes and misdemeanors for an
unprecedented second time
reconvening under the threat of
continued violence and the protection of
thousands of national guard troops the
house was determined to hold trump to
account just one week before
he was to leave office at issue was his
role in encouraging a mob that attacked
the capital one week ago while congress
met to affirm president-elect joe
biden's victory forcing lawmakers to
flee for their lives
in a deadly rampage the house adopted
that single article of impeachment
voting 232-197 to charge trump with
inciting violence against the government
of the united states the 10 republicans
who voted
in favor of impeachment or
representatives liz cheney of wyoming
she's the number three in the house
jamie herrera butler of washington john
cacco of new york adam kinzinger
of illinois fred upton in michigan dan
new house of washington peter maher
of michigan anthony gonzalez of ohio
david valladio
of california and tom rice of south
carolina
so the media of course are treating all
of these republicans with the
strange new respect to which all
republicans are treated any time
the left is happy with them the minute
that these republicans vote for
republican proposals in the future or
vote against joe biden's
joe biden's proposals then of course
they will revert right back into being
deplorable awful horrible people and to
understand
why there was a lot of republican
opposition to these charges
you have to understand that underlying
all of this
underlying all of this is serious doubt
about motives so on the left
there is this attempt to suggest that if
you opposed the impeachment in any way
if you supported trump in any way then
you were in favor of the capital riots
right this was the idea that if you
didn't support impeachment it's because
you were in league with the writers or
you were okay with the rioters
and not just if you didn't vote for
impeachment in the house but also if
you're just a republican broadly
speaking
that this is something you are okay with
if you opposed impeachment and
republicans could sense that and so the
reaction is okay well we're not going to
give you a club with which to beat us
see the democratic argument on
impeachment which i wrote about in this
morning's political playbook
the democratic argument on impeachment
goes something like this president trump
didn't just incite the violence
president trump's actions and the
reaction to those actions
was so foreseeable that from the moment
he came down the escalator any single
person who has supported anything
that donald trump did has done anybody
who supported him in either 2016 or 2020
or both
all of those people should have known
that this was going to be the logical
culmination
of his presidency was going to be people
attempting to sack the capital and kill
lawmakers
that that was absolutely foreseeable
from the get-go now
that line which has been trotted out
about a million times
since last week that line what it really
is attempting to do
is it's not a referendum on trump it is
not an
indictment of trump's character it's an
indictment of anybody who ever supported
trump ever
right which means 74 million americans
who voted for him this time plus tens of
millions of americans who supported any
of his policies
many people who didn't vote in other
words if you don't vote for joe biden if
you don't mirror the democratic agenda
then this makes you a bad person right
you are you're in league with the
capital riders you should have known
that this was going to happen
and you turned a blind eye because you
are just a horrible human being
republicans can sense that this is the
camel's nose under the tent
as they say that the goal of impeachment
for many members of the left
is not to get rid of trump one day
before he's going to leave office anyway
because realistically speaking even if
the senate were to reconvene in
emergency session
today and even if they were to take
three or four days to do an
investigation which again there's never
been an investigation done that fast in
any impeachment trial ever
even if the senate were to do hearings
that quickly
that means that he would leave like two
days before his term was set to expire
anyway
so it isn't about getting rid of trump
so much as it is about suggesting
that everybody anywhere who supported
trump was complicit
in what happened during the capital
riots and therefore that the perspective
of all of those people
ought to be shelved that the perspective
of all of those people broadly writ
that it's that it's entwined with what
happened with the capital riots that the
capital riots were basically a
flashpoint
demonstrating how evil this ideology is
and the ideology needs to be extirpated
and excised from american life
this is why folks on the right have been
looking at the reaction to the capital
riots and saying
yeah the capital rights are evil and
horrible also i'm really really upset
and scared
about what exactly is going on in the
country that right-wingers generally
speaking conservatives generally
speaking are now being targeted by
social media we are afraid of what comes
next we
don't believe that there is a single
standard that is even that is even being
attempted here
folks on the left keep pointing at the
right saying you guys are engaging in
what about ism because people on the
right keep pointing to
democratic behavior during the summer
during the black lives matter and antifa
riots
and people on the right say no no that's
not what about isn't that's us grasping
for some
neutral standard that can be applied to
both sides and this applies to
impeachment also what is the actual
standard under which trump
is actually being tried right under
under which he was impeached yesterday
so the actual standard according to the
democratic charge was
incitement to violence the problem is
for a lot of folks on the right
and i think anybody of sound mind you
look at that incitement charge and you
say okay so
what exactly is the incitement really
like be very specific about what the
incitement is is it using
very passionate colorful language
because
the supreme court has found that that is
not actually incitement not only that
people use that kind of language on a
regular basis right yesterday louis
gohmert
republican in the house big trump
supporter louis gomer read off a bunch
of quotes from democrats
about violence and unrest and use of
violence
and people on the left clipped out the
beginning of that quote
where he says and nancy pelosi said x
and then they just clipped what he said
and they said he's encouraging violence
which of course proved his exact point
which is that if you are going to
impeach trump for incitement to violence
on this standard there are a lot of
politicians who are going to get held at
that standard but that's the point
there is no actual standard there is
just a club okay how about the idea that
trump had to be impeached
because trump was doubting the outcome
of an election he wouldn't accept the
outcome of an election
again folks on the right are saying well
you guys were perfectly happy to not
accept the outcome of the 2016 election
he spent four years claiming that it was
russian propaganda that trump had won
that was russian collusion that led to
trump's win stacey abrams was treated as
the governor of georgia at the
democratic national convention
this year so what exactly is the
standard by which you are holding trump
to account now
you can make the broader political
argument that what trump did
in pitting the executive branch against
the legislature what trump did
in suggesting that congress could do
something that congress had no power to
do and the vice president
was was being forced into a position of
trying of trump wanting him to do
something unconstitutional
that that is impeachable right that's
the standard cheney took and that i
actually hear but that wasn't the charge
that democrats were putting forth
and democrats were putting forth a bunch
of charges they would never apply to
themselves
i tweeted out yesterday the only kind of
standards right now are double standards
and double standards
are the worst kind of lie and that is
why so many people on the right are
saying no no you know whatever we think
of trump's behavior
and i firmly believe that in the heart
of hearts most republicans most
conservatives look at his behavior and
kind of appalled by it that no matter
that
what the left is attempting to do is
paint all of us with that brush
that the left's behavior over the last
week has really been
a in a justification of trump's
long stated rationale for his own power
which is
he says the reason that they're
attacking me is because they want to
attack you
and again the proof is in the pudding
because we've seen a lot of that this
week
i don't think it's holy that i think
there's some people on the left who
legitimately wants to separate between
people who supported trump it's a it's a
two-party system
people voted for trump people who are
conservative and the worst aspects of
trump but i think that that is
far from the rule in in democratic
circles at this point which is really a
problem
it's really really a problem i'll give
you a perfect example so last night
don lemon the end of the democratic
party he's just a democratic mouthpiece
so don lemon really just laid it out
there he he legitimate so chris cuomo
was with him and when chris cuomo was
the voice of reason in a room you know
things have gone wildly wrong so chris
cuomo on cnn was saying
are you really trying to suggest that
every trump supporter is responsible for
what happened
during the capital riots and zon lemon
said yeah i am
yeah i am if you supported trump you
were in league with the kkk you're in
league with capital rioters
you're in league with segregationists
here is don lemon just smearing every
single conservative in america with the
capital riots
republicans know you're doing this we
have eyes and we know that there are
consequences to accepting that version
of reality
the consequences is we the consequences
we all
get excised and marginalized from the
public conversation and so
our answer is no we are not going to go
along with whatever you want us to do
right that is what is driving so much
opposition to the impeachment by
republicans because after all
republicans were in that house too those
republicans were being attacked largely
by trump trump was spending more ire on
mike pence than he was on the democrats
trump was spending more ire on the
governor of georgia and the secretary of
state of georgia than he was on the
democratic senate candidates republicans
were trump's targets
far more than democrats were over the
last two months he was suggesting that
they were
somehow disloyal so republicans you know
are not are the ones who are taking the
brunt of trump not democrats and
nonetheless
when you lump everybody together like
this this is the problem
if you want to go forward as a country
you have to stop lumping every single
person together with the worst
aspects of the other side you have to
stop setting standards that you yourself
do not hold to here was don lemon
doing precisely the opposite last night
if you voted for trump you voted for the
person
who the clan supported you voted for the
who nazis support you voted for the
person who the alt-right
supports that's the crowd that you are
in
you voted for the person who incited a
crowd
to go into the capital and and
potentially
take the lives of lawmakers took the
lives of police officers
took the lives of innocent lives who
were there on the capitol that day
you voted on that side
you voted on that side you see right you
you intentionally did it you knew this
was gonna happen
you you were aware of the possibility
that this was going to happen
and you voted for that side okay you
know how easy it is
to say the same about the other side
it's really really easy to say that
every single democrat who voted for joe
biden was totally fine
with the black lives matter riots that
wrecked cities and got people killed
every single person on the left was
totally fine with antifa
after all joe biden said antifa is an
ideology here's the thing i don't think
every single democrat is okay with that
stuff
in fact i think most democrats are not
okay with that stuff i think one of the
reasons joe biden ended up as
president-elect
is because many democrats rejected that
kind of radicalism from other members of
the party
nonetheless this is the narrative from
the left and because of that narrative
there cannot be unity even in a time
where there should be unity as always as
always whenever i say there should be
unity
i don't mean you have to agree with me i
mean that there is a political approval
of the basic idea that violence is bad
in american life
90 of americans believe this but many of
the elites don't believe this
many of the people who are in media
believe that violence on one side
is okay they just think on your side
it's not okay
many of the elites believe that evidence
is unnecessary to prove
basic contentions about american life
only on their side on the other side you
need evidence right when trump says
widespread voter fraud you need evidence
when we say america is a semicolonly
racist country and every single
discrepancy between performance of
groups is due to that innate american
racism
we don't need any evidence of that when
you back that sort of double standard no
one is going to unify with you because
you are being dishonest you do not
deserve unity if you are being dishonest
in your standards
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first if you are looking to get
rid of nagging muscle joint pain
cramping back aches immediately while
providing yourself long-lasting recovery
you need to try the natural breakthrough
pain relief solution cryo-free sport
roll-on
developed by omax health omax's new
sport formulation includes
a deeply penetrating potent punch of 8.5
of fca approved menthol levels to
instantly ice out and block pain
receptors reduce inflammation
improve muscle and joint flexibility the
best part is this 100 natural remedy
works its magic within five
minutes of application relief lasts up
to eight hours it's much longer than
over-the-counter products you'll
immediately
feel less stiffness and more mobility it
makes a big difference for me
unfortunately my body is aging along
with me i have a birthday tomorrow and
as i approach
40 yes i know i'm turning 37 tomorrow
i'm gonna need i'm gonna need
omax cryofreeze sport i just it's gonna
be a thing i need
omax health is offering my listeners 20
off a full bottle of cryo-free sport
pain relief roll-on
this discount also applies toward any
product site-wide just head on over to
omaxhealth.com today
enter code ben that is omax health dot
com
enter code men to get 20 off cryo free
sport and site wide
cryosport is clinically tested
scientifically proven recommended by top
physical therapists chiropractors
and athletic trainers worldwide the
product reviews speak for themselves 95
5 star reviews page after page of
customers saying they've tried
everything and omax's cryo-free sport is
so good they're now buying it for family
and friends i've been having chronic
knee pen i cannot wait to use cryofree's
sport it is ideal for athletes active
people those with injuries those looking
for long-lasting relief plus quick
recovery you'll probably qualify in one
of those categories
cryo-free sport it works within five
minutes of application improving
physical training recovery and
performance so head on over to
omaxhealth.com enter
code ben to get 20 off cryo-free sport
and site-wide i'm telling you the
product's the real deal head on over to
omax health omax
health.com enter code ben to get 20 off
sitewide
okay so again the basic idea here is the
democrats goal here
is not to get rid of trump primarily the
goal
is the political goal the goal is
everybody on the right
is with trump and trump is with the
rioters by the transit of property
you are with the rioters and just like
the rioters have been excised from
american life as well they should be
because they are criminals you should
also be excised from american life this
is utterly foreseeable
you and the rioters are tied at the hip
trump is the glue that holds you and the
rioters together
and so if you voted for trump just to
oppose joe biden or you liked a lot of
what trump did but you didn't like his
personality or he liked trump's
personality but you didn't expect this
to happen
you are still glued together with the
people who decided to violate the seat
of democracy
and try to harm congress people and
legislators and the vice president of
the united states
people on the right see that and when
the media keep repeating that line over
and over
it's not hard to see why people on the
right believe that the social fabric is
frayed because
social fabric gets afraid when people
doubt each other's motives okay and and
when one side is basically
openly suggesting that the other side is
evil all the time
i talk about this on the program a lot
people on the left have a tendency to
believe that people on the right are
legitimately evil right in 2016 they
couldn't believe that trump won
because they thought that anyone who
opposed barack obama or hillary clinton
was evil and so their first reaction was
i can't believe there are so many evil
people in the country not maybe we were
wrong
not maybe we ought to investigate the
the minds of the people who didn't vote
for us
there was about a five-minute period
where they were interested in that and
then they went right back to
trump is a white supremacist and all the
people who support him are white
supremacists
and now they get to fall back because
biden won they're now falling back
on that same hackneyed and vile
misinterpretation of american life
and impeachment is just their latest
attempt to do this
people on the right can see this so it's
really not about
what trump did for a lot of folks a lot
of folks like again i i think good
hearted people can disagree on
impeachment i have a lot of friends who
are pro-impeachment on the right i have
a lot of friends who are
anti-impeachment on the right i have a
lot of friends who are pro-censure on
the right
but what i think is that those those
arguments many of which are principled
some of which are prudential i talked
about this at length yesterday
they take a back seat overall for the
future to the broader question
of whether we can live together and if
one side of the political aisle is
determined to lump 74 million americans
minimum
because those americans have kids they
have relatives who didn't vote so you're
really talking about
easily over 120 million americans if
you're determined to lump
that many americans into one group of
deplorables
then we can't it's going to be very
difficult for us to have a country in
the future because we can't even
solidify around basic notions like
violence in politics and generally is
bad
and claims deserve evidence we can't
even unify around that
okay so the democrats did not make
things any easier yesterday with their
impeachment talk
because again it's just too easy to
point to the fact that democrats have
one standard for themselves and one
standard for everybody else so nancy
pelosi led
off the debate yesterday she said we
have a sacred obligation to stand for
truth
and i can i can actually audibly hear
the audience rolling their eyes like i
can hear your eyeballs rolling in your
head
when you hear nancy pelosi saying that
she has a sacred obligation to stand for
truth
after spending months delaying a relief
package over kovad for specifically
political purposes
and here's nancy pelosi saying she has a
secret obligation to stand for truth
our country is divided we all know that
there are lies abroad in the land spread
by a desperate president
who feels his power slipping away
we know that too but i know this as well
that we here in this house have a sacred
obligation
to stand for truth to stand
up for the constitution to stand as
guardians of the republic
yeah again when you hear nancy pelosi
talking about obligations to the
constitution
you think to yourself literally this
week you you tried to pass a resolution
pushing mike pence into invoking the
25th amendment which by the way is not a
constitutional procedure that is an
executive branch initiated move the 25th
amendment
earlier this week nancy pelosi wrote a
letter to the joint chiefs of staff
asking them to ignore orders from
president trump which again
is unconstitutional okay so great
defender of the constitution now
by the way nancy pelosi has not been any
stranger to using inflammatory language
back in 2018
when she was talking about the family
separation policies at the border
she said she didn't know why there
aren't uprisings all over the country
could that have been inflammatory at all
the evangelicals testified that the
silent refugees in scion
that is the they called it the crown
jewel of america's
humanitarianism crown jewel of american
humanitarianism
and in order to do away with that crown
jewel
they're doing away with children being
with their moms
this is i i just don't even know why
there aren't uprisings all over the
country and maybe there will be
when people realize uh that this is
a policy that they defend
okay so yeah again this kind of language
passionate language and politics has
always been a part of politics
and i think everybody should be a little
bit careful about immediately going to
incitement of violence is what happened
when your evidence of incitement is
actually not up to the legal standard
you can say that bad things have been
said you can say that raising the
temperature is bad
and i've said this many many times to
people on both sides of the political
aisle
but the the nancy pelosi of the world
standing there and saying you know
heightened language is really dangerous
sure nancy sure
and meanwhile corey bush who began her
political life as a black lives matter
activist
she of course immediately linked this to
race so i'm not sure what the evidence
is
that this had anything to do with raise
remember that this was an outgrowth of
trump
continually saying that he had won the
election and that he was being
he was being robbed of the election by a
voting fraud infrastructure that spread
across the country
and all this i'm not sure what that has
to do with white supremacy but democrats
are always eager
to lump everything into the white
supremacist box specifically so they can
claim their opposition is a bunch of
racists because the worst thing you can
call somebody in american life right now
as well should be is a racist that's why
some of us say before you call somebody
a racist maybe you ought to examine
whether they're actually racist
but democrats don't do that at all they
just throw the term racist around or now
white supremacist is their favorite they
throw white supremacists around it
anybody
who acts badly i mean you can condemn
the riots without
suggesting that the riots had anything
to do with race but this was immediately
determined by the democrats right
immediately after the riots it turned to
well it's probably happening because the
cops are racist and if that had been a
black lives matter riot then they for
sure would have shot everybody and it's
like okay hold up a second
over the summer in washington dc there
were massive black lives matter riots
and the police shot nobody so i'm gonna
i'm gonna have some questions about that
doesn't matter everything is viewed
through the prism of race specifically
so again
you can lump together everybody who
supports trump with white supremacy
this is the goal and then you wonder why
republicans
largely are like you know what i'm not
going along with whatever you want to do
here because i don't think it's about
trump i think it's about me
hey here was corey bush doing this
routine yesterday
if we failed to remove a white
supremacist president
who incited a white supremacist
insurrection it's communities like
missouri's first district that suffer
the most
the 117th congress must understand that
we have a mandate
to legislate in defense of black lives
the first step in that process is to
root out
white supremacy starting with impeaching
the white supremacist
in chief uh so president trump needs to
be impeached because he's the white
supremacist in chief now i just have a
question
what in the world over the last two
months has had to do with white
supremacy
like really what i understand this
argument back when you were talking
about like
charlottesville even though you were
deliberately misinterpreting some of the
things that trump said
i get it i get what you were at least
attempting to do there at least there
was some connection between the
alt-right and trump and it was about the
alt-right and all this
i i don't know what you were talking
when trump says the election was stolen
from me which is a false claim
when he says that what in the world that
can be bad and also not white
supremacists but again
everything has to tie into this
underlying great moral battle
between the wonderful tolerant
democratic party and all of their
enemies who unite
in the new buzzword in their white
supremacy again there is no evidence
none that what trump has been doing over
the last two months is quote unquote
tied to white supremacy and yet this has
been
the talking point which is such a
bizarre talking point
like you don't need that talking point
you could just say that trump engaged in
prevarications and then he led people
down primrose path to hell in some cases
by
pushing them to believe things that are
not true about the united states
about the electoral system about the
powers of congress you can do
like all of those things but to go to
white supremacy is really just a moral
attempt to bludgeon
everybody who disagrees with you on any
subject that's the goal here
maxine waters did the same thing we'll
get to maxine waters in just one second
first
let us talk about the fact that perhaps
you're unhappy with your smile
perhaps you know years and years and
years ago you had braces and then
after you got the braces off you got a
retainer and then you lost the retainer
and now your teeth have slipped out of
place well if you're unhappy with your
smile you don't have to be
thousands of people have used candid the
clear comfortable removable practically
invisible aligners to help straighten
their teeth and now they love that smile
don't take my word for it sharon from
pittsburgh says i wore braces as a
teenager flash forward 30 years i had
crowding on the bottom of my teeth
actually stuck out
that's when i made the decision to move
forward with candid and i finally got my
confidence back candid
is here to help straighten your teeth so
you can fall in love with your smile as
well
their treatment is prescribed and
closely monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement you'll have the same quality of
care you'd get
from an in-office orthodontist from the
comfort and convenience of your own home
while other companies use general
dentists candid only works with
orthodontist with candid the same
orthodontist who created your plan is
with you from start to finish so you
never have to wonder how you're doing
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start seeing results way
before then it costs thousands of bucks
less than traditional braces become your
best use start straightening
your teeth today right now you can save
75 bucks on candid starter kit head on
over to candidco.com
shapiro use code shapiro that is
candidco.com shapiro code shapiro take
advantage of this limited time offer to
save 75 bucks on your starter kit
candidco.com shapiro use code shapiro
okay so
maxine waters pushing this line as well
everybody is trump
trump is the rioters all of you are the
same an
ugly a divisive uh a a
pathetic line that happens to be untrue
and false and vile but again
this is all tied into the impeachment
effort imagine if democrats said listen
we know that trump voters do not approve
of what just happened
at the riot we know that you don't
approve of that and we know that even
the people who went to the rally
did not approve in the vast majority of
cases i mean we were talking like
they're probably a couple hundred
thousand people who went to that rally
and like a couple of hundred people who
broke into the capital
the vast majority of the people who were
actually at the rally may believe
something that's not true but they
certainly didn't approve of people
invading the capitol building and
attempting to do violence to legislators
right this is solely and completely
about trump's behavior in the lead-up to
the election is not about you
we understand that you guys disagree
with us we understand you voted for
trump because you may disagree with some
of our priorities
but this is really about we as the
legislature have to stand up
for our for our own domain if they had
said that it would have removed a lot of
the club from the hands of republicans
who didn't want to vote for impeachment
would it not
made it very difficult for but democrats
but that wouldn't serve their political
purposes you see
because for many democrats not all but
for many democrats the goal
is to lump everybody in together for
political gain because this this
impeachment effort
is part and parcel of something larger
which is the attempt to silence people
on the right know this people on the
left are dismissing it
because they don't want to they don't
want to pay attention to it because
again
for many on the left this is the goal he
said here is maxine waters again if
you're going to trot out people to talk
about
the evils of incitement you cannot trot
out maxine waters maxine waters
spent the la riots explaining they were
in la uprising
okay while people were getting killed in
south central l.a
she was claiming it was an uprising
against the system yet here was maxine
waters yesterday talking about how the
republican party is the trump party and
trump is going to start a civil war
and he has to be stopped right now the
republican party is now
the trump party and i want you to know
that this is a trump power grab that
will not stop
it will not stop with attacking the
capital and our state legislatures
this president intends to exercise power
long
after he is out of office we should be
concerned
that the republicans will not defend him
and he is capable of starting a civil
war
he must be impeached he must be stopped
now
okay and that is the same maxine waters
who just a couple of years ago was
suggesting
that every republican in america who
supported trump needed to be confronted
physically here was maxine waters
talking to supporters just a few years
ago
if you see anybody from that cabinet in
a restaurant
in a department store at a gasoline
station
you get out and you create a crowd
and you push back on them and you tell
them they are not
welcome anymore anywhere
okay so again that is maxine waters
telling you how bad political violence
and incitement are
i'm sorry from acting waters that
doesn't hold a lot of water
it just does not and you have the that's
not even the most extreme rhetoric we
saw from democrats yesterday during this
impeachment hearing
right we have we have eric swalwell
comparing donald trump to
osama bin laden osama bin laden
did not enter u.s soil on september 11
but it was widely acknowledged that he
was responsible for
inspiring the attack on our country and
the president with his words using the
words
fight with the speakers that he
assembled that day who called for trial
by combat
are you comparing president trump to
osama bin laden i'm comparing
the words of a individual who would
incite and radicalize somebody as osama
bin laden did to what
president trump did you don't actually
have to commit the violence yourself
okay i'm sorry that's insane that is
insane osama bin laden didn't just say
mean things
on the twitters osama bin laden actively
planned fomented
and achieved terrorist attacks ending
with the murder of thousands of american
citizens not quite the same thing
they're eric swalwell
it's always fun to hear about national
security from a guy who is literally in
bed with a chinese spy that's all that's
always fun
okay meanwhile representative clark this
would be catherine clark
she says that the president of the
united states has spent his entire
his entire administration fomenting
white supremacy again the goal here is
to lump everybody together because that
has predictable effect
that has predicted when you lump
everybody together then you get to
censor everybody that's the fun of the
game
so here is catherine clark yesterday the
truth is
president trump incited a violent attack
against the united states government
the truth is president trump spent his
presidency
inflaming hate white supremacy
anti-semitism
and violence the truth is he was enabled
by
all those who perpetuated the lie
that the most secure election in our
nation's history was stolen
the truth is that these seditious
actions
left five dead our capital besieged our
security threatened
in our democracy hanging in the balance
right the the argument that trump has
done this all along it was utterly
inevitable so that means if you voted
for him he knew it was inevitable that's
your fault
and that is that is the goal here and
there are ramifications to this
right we can see the ramifications
happening in real time
because if you believe not just that
trump did something wrong but that
everybody who agrees with trump
is engaged in quasi-violent action then
the proper response is to shut them down
and that is precisely what we are seeing
calls for from the same left that says
it's really just about trump we really
just don't like his behavior really then
why is nicholas kristof writing in
today's new york times that advertisers
should boycott fox news
why is thomas friedman celebrating the
fall of the republican party more
generally
it seems as though there might be a
secondary agenda here and the secondary
agenda might actually be the primary
agenda for a lot of people
for a lot of people it seems that maybe
the doubts about motivation
are justified we'll get to that in just
one second first
this this year has been insane news here
it means that you've been listening to a
lot of content
this year is an insane year you can't
leave your house for large swaths of the
year and so you've been consuming a lot
of media this means you need a great
pair of wireless earbuds so let me talk
to you about the best wireless earbuds
raycons whether it's following
directions in the kitchen binging an
audiobook while learning to knit or
powering through a new workout with a
pumped up playlist in your ear a pair of
raycons can make any activity easier
and a better time raycon makes great
sound accessible to everyone their
wireless earbuds start at half the price
of other premium audio brands and guess
what
if you think having those white stems
dangling out of your ears makes you look
like a bug that's something you don't
have to worry about with raycons they
come in a range of stylish colors
and they have a range of fits as well so
it's going to fit perfectly in your ear
always looks more discreet and they
don't just look great raycons perform
wherever you take them six hours of
playtime
water and sweat resistant construction
bluetooth that pairs quickly
and seamlessly you've heard me say it
all before if you still don't have a
pair of raycons
gotta start wondering why raycon is
offering 15 off all their products for
my listeners here's what you've got to
do to get it go to buy recon dot com
slash ben
that's it you get 15 off your entire
recon order so feel free to grab a pair
and a spare that is 15
off at buy raycon dot com slash ben by
raycon
dot com slash ben okay so
when people on the right say i feel like
you're talking about more than
impeachment when you're talking about
impeachment
they're not wrong to be suspicious okay
nicholas kristoff has a piece in the new
york times today
in which he says that we have to tackle
the ecosystem
the ecosystem you mean free speech
that's that would be the ecosystem he's
talking about
he says the united states realized after
9 11 that to succeed in the war on
terror it had to reform extremist
madrasas religious schools that preached
hatred
today the equivalent of those madrasas
are online platforms and right-wing
bloviators and again we face complicated
free speech issues
okay so extremist madrasas where people
were literally
being taught that america was the great
satan and israel was the
the little satan and that people who
disagreed were infidels that is the
equivalent of right-wing bloviators you
see that is the equivalent
of basic free speech online platforms
it's the same thing the same exact thing
according to
nicholas kristof in other words a
propaganda wing is the same thing as
people who disagree with me politically
i love this from kristoff he says i
believe in listening to alternative
voices not drowning them out
that's why i went to extremist mocks in
pakistan it's why i had an account on
parlor but i also saw how fanatical
mosques inculcated violence
and how alex jones sean hannity and
donald trump used their platforms to
spew racism bigotry and conspiracy
theories in ways that made america a
more frightening place
so what should be done about these evil
people according to nicholas kristoff
they have first amendment rights
but not a right to advertising or to
private platforms so i'd like to see
pressure on advertisers to withdraw from
fox news so long as it functions as an
extremist madrasa
and cable providers should also be asked
why they distribute channels the pedal
lies
so you're in favor of the first
amendment just you don't want anybody to
be able to take advantage of the first
amendment to actually speak to people
so that's fun it's sort of like the left
view of freedom of religion that you
should be able to be as religious as you
want to be so long as you're in the
privacy of your bedroom the minute you
leave your bedroom then you can't be
religious in any shape
like any way shape or form you can't
teach your kids religious stuff you
really shouldn't i mean that would be
bad we can't have religious schools that
are funded by school vouchers we have to
make sure that your churches
is fully ensconced and left its values
in your home that's that's the place for
so free speech it's the place for you
and like your immediate family but
we have to deny online platforms to
people i disagree with somehow i don't
trust nicholas christoph's definition
of of content that is the equivalent of
an extremist madrasa if he is now
equating
sean hannity to extremist madrasas
somehow i don't i'm not seeing the
connection there nick
i'm not sure why i should trust you with
those sorts of standards also i find it
very interesting
i've never seen folks on the right call
for widespread advertiser boycotts of
people on the left who say awful awful
things
on a regular basis in fact i used to run
an organization called truth revolt it
was deliberately designed to be the
response to media matters
because media matters does this all the
time right they go to right-wing shows
they find their advertisers and then
they try to asteroids
boycotts they get 12 people to call and
then they try to get the advertiser to
feel uncomfortable and pull their money
so we created an organization called
truth revolt the explicit goal of the
organization
was what we call mutually assured
destruction we said this tactic is bad
it is bad for the country but until the
left learns that the tactic is bad
they're going to keep pursuing it well
they are going to keep pursuing it they
continue to pursue it
and by the way the only way out for the
right may be to actually
do the opposite okay which makes the
country worse on every level
okay so again the idea here is the
is the the people i disagree with ought
to be deplatformed
meanwhile you got thomas friedman also
in the new york times talking about how
it's great
that the gop is being blown apart by
this
he says well i want trump out i'm not
sure i want him permanently off twitter
and facebook not because thomas friedman
likes free speech mind you but because
thomas friedman enjoys the fact that
donald trump is providing a political
albatross for republicans and maybe this
will allow democrats to win more seats
he says there's important work i need
trump to perform in his post-presidency
i need him to have proper megaphones to
do it
it's to blow apart this republican party
my number one wish for america today
says thomas friedman is for this
republican party to fracture
that would be a blessing for america
first it could end gridlock in congress
and enable us to do big things on
infrastructure education and healthcare
that would help
all americans if just a few principled
central right republicans abandoned the
gop
or were willing to work with the central
left biden team the problem solvers
caucus in the house and like-minded
members of the senate would become
stronger
than ever also if the principled
republicans split from the trump cult
the rump pro-trump gop would have a hard
time winning a national election anytime
soon
and um that would be good only democrats
should win only democrats should win
so thomas friedman is actually eager to
have more trump because he thinks that
this will lead
to democrats continuing to win so i'm
getting the impression that you're
really not all that upset with with
with trump particularly thomas i'm
getting the impression what you're
really upset with
is the fact that there is opposition and
so if you can get rid of the opposition
via the vehicle of trump
then you are happy to do it that is the
impression that i'm getting because
you're saying it
out loud okay like you're saying the
quiet part out loud there
by the way when when it comes to the
silencing of dissenting viewpoints the
silencing of dissenting
voices worth noting ar15.com
has now been kicked off godaddy okay
they are one of the
largest if not the largest big gun
biggest uh gun forum in the world they
would be platformed
on monday by godaddy they were not given
an excuse
the president and co-founder of the gun
site juan avila told the federalist
quote
on monday i received notice from our
site registrar that ar15 had violated
their terms of service and that ar15.com
would be shut down immediately
the registrar's decision to de-platform
ar-15 was final
no method of appeal was offered it
remains unclear specifically what
content allegedly violated the
registrar's terms of service
when asked by the federalist godaddy
claimed the site quote both promotes and
encourages violence but offered no
specific examples
instead they just said you have 24 hours
to get off of our platform
meanwhile you remember that time that um
the
the amazon web services banned parlor
remember that
where they said that the parlor was
super duper terrible and needed to be
removed
because obviously people had been
spending an enormous amount of time
planning evil
on parlor remember that well we're now
learning
that actually actually it was uh it was
largely planned on both twitter and
facebook
whoops so when do we get when do those
sites get deplatformed
seriously when do they get deplatformed
if the standard is
that anybody any any
platform that was used to foment
violence or organize violence or
organize rallies that devolved into
violence
needs to be held accountable for all of
this then i have a question which is
when does parlor
get its platform back and when do
facebook
and twitter get removed the washington
post has a piece today titled
facebook's sandberg deflected blame for
capital riot but new evidence
shows how platform played role flyers
and hashtags promoting the pro-trump
rally circulated on facebook and
instagram
in in the days and weeks beforehand in
the days leading up to last week's march
on the capitol
says the washington post supporters of
president trump promoted it extensively
on facebook and facebook owned instagram
and used the services to organize bus
trips to washington more than a hundred
thousand users posted hashtags
affiliated with the movement
prompted by baseless claims of election
fraud including stop the steal
and fight for trump so facebook services
um were in fact used
to organize a lot of this material oh
weird so i guess that uh we now have to
take down facebook right we took down
parlor on this basis
so i guess that we have to take down
facebook as well by the way apparently
we should also be taking down according
to the ap twitter
according to the associated press
defense and national guard officials
have said in interviews they were told
by dc they believed the protest would be
similar to the ones in november and
december
they said federal law enforcement
authorities said there was activity on
twitter
but they weren't expecting the level of
violence that they ultimately saw
last wednesday oh look at that level of
activity on twitter
oh well look at well i guess we have to
do platform
twitter and facebook or it could be that
the social media giants actually have no
actual standard
and that the standard is if we don't
like a particular app because we believe
that too many right wingers are using it
we'll just take it down
i wonder why so many people are doubtful
of the motives here i wonder why so many
people feel like
a lot of this is is not genuine rage
which we all share at the capitol riots
but is
a is a trojan horse for something larger
that this is going to be used as a club
a cudgel to wield against the ability of
republicans to be platformed to speak
freely to have advertisers to say what
they want to have conversations and
discussions with others
again that's partner that's part of a
broader trend in the united states
tomorrow is my birthday and it's a day
when i like to play one of my favorite
games
it's a game i call the happy birthday
game and here's how the game goes
i receive texts from all of my friends
in the liberal media
in liberal hollywood and then i see how
many of them actually post happy
birthday on twitter
and the answer is usually close to zero
and so i keep count
because it's fun because for anybody on
the left to recognize
that i am a human being born of woman
would be bad for them publicly
right this is part and parcel of the
othering of half of america the right
can sense it
they're not wrong to sense it they're
not wrong to fear it and they are not
wrong to recognize that there will be an
attempt
both socially and governmentally to
crack down on them
via any instrument available if many on
the left get that chance
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second and we're gonna tell you
what is next
there's a possibility of violence over
the weekend the impeachment itself is
going nowhere in the senate at least
nowhere fast
and president trump puts out a statement
um roundly
roundly uh ripping on on violence we'll
get to that in just
one moment first let us talk about the
fact that
you need better sleep i need better
sleep we all need better sleep but i was
in a hotel
last night and that meant that i was not
on my bull and branch sheets okay that
means i didn't sleep as well because
bowling branch sheets are the best
sheets in the land the signature hem
cheese from bowling branch are a
bestseller for a reason
buttery soft lightweight organic cotton
in a classic sateen weave for sheets
that get softer over time they're not
too hot they're not too cool they are
the perfect year-round sheets for most
sleepers
bullet and branch focuses on quality
over quantity no inflated thread counts
here because more isn't always better
it's not about the thread count it's
about the quality
bowling branch signature sheets come in
seven beautiful colors in all sizes from
twin
all the way up to california king
they're made to a higher standard 100
organic cotton
ethical production thoughtful attention
to every detail there's nothing worse
than fitted sheets that don't fit
bowling branch offers 17-inch deep
fitted sheets and labeled sides to help
you make your bed beautifully
every single time the little things make
a difference
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt at bowlingbranch.com they're so
good my wife and i tossed out all our
other sheets we only have
bowl and branch now get 15 off your
first set of sheets when you use promo
code shapiro at checkout that's bull and
branch b-o-l-l
and branch dot com bull and branch dot
promo code shapiro go check us out
right now alrighty so before we get to
more and there's much much more that we
have to discuss here because it has been
a rather large day well tonight is a big
big night for the daily wear tonight
daily wire makes its entrance into
entertainment content with our first
feature film run hide fight 7 pm eastern
4 p.m pacific
we will air a virtual premiere of the
movie in a special episode of backstage
it'll stream live over at the daily wire
website
mobile and streaming apps as well as on
our youtube channel tonight's event
is free for everyone to watch but after
the live stream is over the movie will
be available exclusively to daily wire
members
please be aware the film is not
political it is intense it is for mature
audiences only this is a rated r
edgy film it's got violence it's got
language it starts isabel may thomas
jane
rodden mitchell run hide fight it
follows zoe hall who's a high school
student coping with the recent loss of
her mother
all she wants to do is get through the
last few weeks of senior year and leave
for college with a fresh start instead
her high school is attacked by four
nihilistic gun-toting students with
plans to make the worst school shooting
in history using her wits and survival
skills zoe fights back to save her
fellow students
it's a it's a great movie you're really
going to enjoy it we are excited to
bring you
great stories hollywood refuses to tell
we hope you'll join us for tonight's big
event as we move into entertainment and
start to compete
overtly in the culture at 7pm eastern 4
p.m pacific dailywire.com
apple tv or roku or the daily wire
youtube channel we can't wait we'll see
you there
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
alrighty so you can see the trend
forming in real time again
the whole goal for not all many on the
left a lot of liberals are not in favor
of this but many on the left are very
much in favor of de-platforming
everybody who's on the right you can see
the fallout in corporate america too
by the way as this strengthens the
blowback is going to get worse the
polarization is going to get deeper none
of this is healing or unifying
it's not geared toward that it is geared
toward
toward essentially calling for the
submission of people who disagree with
you
charles schwab is now discontinuing its
political action committee instead it's
going to donate all the remaining funds
to the boys and girls club of america
and historically black colleges
and universities they say in light of a
divided political climate and an
increase in attacks on those who
participated in the political process
we believe a clear and apolitical
position is in the best interest of our
clients
and meanwhile at t and marriott are
among the companies that will stop
all election contributions to lawmakers
who objected to certifying the election
weird they didn't do that to like jamie
raskin in maryland
after he voted against certifying the
election in
or tried to stop the certification of
the election uh in 2016 in florida right
he is actually on the house impeachment
team for nancy pelosi didn't have a
barbara boxer
it didn't happen this summer when people
were overtly
siding with rioters in the democratic
party there was no corporate
disassociation from
from various candidates instead there
was actually a closer tie between the
candidates
and corporate america and and on the
interpersonal level we're seeing this as
well
a university of michigan regent is now
under fire his name is ron weiser
according to breitbart
because he replied i don't know when
asked if he believes trump is to blame
for the capitol hill riot last week
now there is a petition that has
garnered 4 000 signatures calling for
wiser to resign
why because he apparently
was in favor of white supremacy the
petition claims that the wiser
stood by the consciously destructive
actions of president trump the day after
white supremacy stormed
america's capital what exactly what did
wiser do
he was asked if trump bears blame for
the wednesday's violent mob he said i
don't know i didn't read any of that
stuff i didn't watch tv i watched
michigan destroy minnesota and
basketball that kind of contest is
something i strongly
support and then the petition says that
wiser's answer is merely a continuation
of refusing to condemn trump's
undisputed endorsement
of white supremacist violence so wiser
wrote i strongly condemn people who
turned into a mob and breached the
capitol after what was supposed to be a
peaceful protest those who broke the law
should be held accountable my heart goes
out to the families
doesn't matter he's still on the
chopping block over at michigan
meanwhile over at uh harvard kennedy
school
they've decided they're going to dump
republican congresswoman elise stefanik
who represents the north country in
upstate
in the northern uh country in upstate
new york according to jazz shaw over at
hot air
she's now being been initiated into the
club of people who have become targets
of cancelled culture
not a huge surprise stephanie graduated
from harvard in 2006
she's mentored students and served on
harvard kennedy school senior advisory
committee now the school is saying that
they will drop her from the position
because she was too closely aligned with
trump
according to dean doug elmendorf he said
following this consideration i spoke
with elise
and asked her to step aside from the
senior advisory committee my request was
not about political parties political
ideology or her choice of candidate for
president
rather in my assessment elise has made
public assertions about voter fraud in
november's presidential election that
have no basis in evidence and she has
made public statements about court
actions related to the election that are
incorrect the dean asked her to resign
she said no um and uh here is what she
said
stephanie put out a statement she said
as a conservative republican it's a
right of passage and badge of honor to
join the long line of leaders who have
been boycotted protested and canceled
by colleges and universities across
america
that's that's right i mean it's fun to
watch as
overt liars from past administrations
are granted
great gigs over at harvard kennedy
school but elise stefanik
is is now canceled that's the way all of
this works so when people on the right
fear that uh this sort of stuff may have
something to do with a
a broader agenda again for the
thousandth time
they are not wrong to have their doubts
so quick note quick final note here
it's not as though even republicans who
opposed impeachment were in favor of
president trump's behavior
okay trip roy put out a statement saying
that the democratic article was flawed
but he said that that trump's activities
over the past few months
were in fact impeachable he just said
that the house article was flawed
so chip roy said that the house
democrats drafted articles which i think
fall short and create issues with
respect to what inciting a riot and
inciting an instruction look like
i think that is a problem but apparently
chip roy is bad because he didn't vote
in favor of impeachment
dan crenshaw has been trending on
twitter all day because he put out a
statement
deploring what president trump has been
saying over the past couple of months
but saying that he was not going to vote
in favor of impeachment he thought that
it was a bad prudential solution to the
issue
he said he would vote in favor of
censure but
that's not enough either if as long as
you're not doing exactly the thing
democrats want you to do this mean
this means that you are part of the the
gang that must be obliterated from the
political face of the earth
and kevin mccarthy's very bad even
though mccarthy said yesterday that
trump bears responsibility for the
attack but won't vote to impeach here's
kevin mccarthy the house minority leader
yesterday
i believe impeaching the president
in such a short time frame would be a
mistake
no investigations have been completed no
hearings
have been held that doesn't mean the
president is free from fault
the president bears responsibility for
wednesday's attack on congress by mob
rioters
he should have immediately denounced the
mob when he saw what was unfolding
these facts require immediate action by
president trump
accept his share of responsibility quell
the brewing unrest and ensure
president-elect biden
is able to successfully begin his term
okay so mccarthy is also bad everybody's
bad you see everybody you don't like is
bad that's the way
that this works okay meanwhile we have
to talk about what is
coming next so there are reports
that um violence may be on the way this
weekend
there are apparently now 20 000 troops
who are guarding the capitol building
which is pretty amazing 20 000 troops in
washington dc a thing that you probably
didn't ever expect to see
in your lifetime according to the
washington post national guard forces
from a growing list of states moved into
positions around washington on wednesday
as authorities scrambled to understand
the extent of threats surrounding
president-elect joe biden's inauguration
and prevent a repeat of last week's
deadly insurrection at us capital
federal officials led tabletop exercises
to rehearse inauguration security
and strengthen coordination among a
massive patchwork of police
national guard troops and federal
personnel that is expected to fan out
ahead of protest this weekend and the
january 20th transfer of power by next
week
the d.c police chief said upward of 20
000 guardsmen were expected to be in
place to guard against violence
days after supporters of president trump
smashed their way into the capital
as lawmakers met to certify biden's
electoral win
so people are where i've been hearing
from my own security sources there's a
lot of chatter about this particular
weekend
apparently they're going to be protests
and armed protests at capitals across
the country
obviously everybody needs to stay safe
president trump put out a statement
in response to all of these rumors and
everything that is going on
talking about the risks of additional
demonstrations and talking about
condemning the violence he says i
condemn the violence and mob violence is
against
what my movement stands for which must
have come as a quite a shock to the q
crowd here was president from condemning
the violence yesterday
i want to be very clear i unequivocally
condemned the violence that we saw last
week
violence and vandalism have absolutely
no place in our country
and no place in our movement mob
violence goes against
everything i believe in and everything
our movement stands for
no true supporter of mind could ever
endorse
political violence no true supporter of
mine could ever disrespect
law enforcement or our great american
flag
okay president trump continued along
these lines we've seen too many riots
and too many mobs
it by the way it happens to be true when
you normalize political violence on one
side of the aisle usually political
violence results on the other side of
the political aisle
uh once the once the violent cat is let
out of the bag
all the cats are out of the bag right
and and this has been a serious problem
that something tom mcclintock said
yesterday on the floor of the house it's
true
imagine if the entire country had come
out at one as one during the blm riots
and said
this violence is unacceptable everybody
who is committing it should not be
justified they should be arrested and
they should be thrown in prison
it definitely would have had i think a
calming impact
unfortunately none of that happened that
is not to excuse anybody who's excusing
violence today
obviously no violence no political
violence and a civilized country should
ever be excused here's president trump
talking about the rioting and the mobs
and he says this mob violence has to
stop this
again this would have been much more
useful about a week ago
we have seen too many riots too many
mobs too many
acts of intimidation and destruction
it must stop now i am asking everyone
who has
ever believed in our agenda to be
thinking of ways to ease tensions
calm tempers and help to promote peace
in our country okay and uh he continued
along these lines as well
and he talked about the potential
threats that are that are arising this
weekend and
up to inauguration uh here was president
trump on that subject
there has been reporting that additional
demonstrations are being planned
in the coming days both here in
washington
and across the country i have been
briefed by the u.s secret service
on the potential threats every american
deserves to have their voice heard
in a respectful and peaceful way that is
your first
amendment right but i cannot emphasize
that there must be
no violence no law breaking and no
vandalism of any kind
obviously uh this this we hope that
everybody takes to heart
and finally trump sounded off on the
efforts to censor cancel and blacklist
this happens to be true as well again i
wish that this statement
had been made a month and a half ago
after the electoral college vote
that would have been the time to do this
but better late than than not at all
here was president trump talking about
the efforts to censor and
censor and cancel and blacklist and and
the problem with the backlash that we
are now experiencing in the country
these are tense and difficult times the
efforts to censor
cancel and blacklist our fellow citizens
are wrong and they are dangerous
what is needed now is for us to listen
to one another
not to silence one another
all of us can choose by our actions
to rise above the rancor and find common
ground and
shared purpose okay so that was
president trump's
statement yesterday meanwhile
mitch mcconnell has announced that this
thing is basically going over the
impeachment
meaning he says we've run out of time he
says the house of representatives has
voted to impeach the president the
senate process will now begin
at our first regular meeting following
receipt of the article from the house
given the rules procedures and senate
precedence that govern
presidential impeachment trials there's
simply no chance that a fair or serious
trial could conclude
before president-elect biden is sworn in
the next week the senate has held three
presidential impeachment trials they've
lasted 83 days 37 days and 21 days
respectively
even if the senate process were to begin
this week and move promptly no final
verdict would be reached until after
trump had left office
this is not a decision i am making it is
a fact the president-elect himself
stated last week his inauguration on
january 20th
is the quickest path for any change in
the occupant of the presidency in light
of this reality i believe it will best
serve our nation if congress and the
executive branch
spent the next seven days completely
focused on facilitating a safe
inauguration
and an orderly transfer of power to the
incoming biden administration i'm
grateful to the offices and institutions
within the capital that are working
around the clock alongside federal and
local law enforcement to prepare for a
safe and successful inauguration
at the capitol next wednesday so in
other words we're out of time
there's really no point to this at this
point since it is now the 14th
and we are you know less than a week
away from the inauguration of joe biden
as the 46th president of the united
states
now there are serious legal questions to
be asked as to whether impeachment can
be pursued after the person leaves
office justice
a judge named michael luddick who's a
very well-respected former court of
appeals judge
he wrote a piece for the washington post
saying not you really can't impeach
people after they are out of office
because they're out of office literally
impeachment is to take them out of
office that's what it means
but there are others who say no you can
actually pursue impeachment as a way of
barring the person
from running for office in the future in
any case
it's going to be a weird spectacle for
americans two months from now to be
talking about the impeachment of a
president who's no longer in office
and um yeah as far as barring trump from
running for future office
presumably there could be some active
censure that could do it i'm not sure
the only way to do that would be
impeachment even if congress wanted
to pursue that so essentially time has
run
and there is not going to be a quick
exit for president trump before
january 20th uh meanwhile democrats are
now making some some rather
extraordinary claims that
i would love to see some others if
there's evidence of this then honestly
this is treasonous activity i mean if
there are actual congress people
who were aiding and embedding the
capital rioters
like bringing them into the capital or
giving them tours of the capital knowing
they were going to
go in and attempt to do violence to
people that actually is insurrection
right now you're talking about an
attempt to overthrow the lawful workings
of the united states congress democrats
have been throwing around this
accusation i am shocked that it has not
been leading every newspaper because
frankly this is the biggest accusation
that's been made it's a bigger
accusation than trump inciting
people right incitement is both a legal
standard and then sort of an informal
standard
on the legal side trump does not meet
the standard of incitement on the on the
social side
i still think that it's kind of dicey
but with that said
isn't the bigger headline if democrats
could actually show evidence of this
if members of congress sitting elected
members of congress were showing
rioters and insurrectionists around the
capitol building in preparation for the
insurrection wouldn't that actually be
the bigger story
and yet i've seen very little pursuit of
this story among members of the media
so maybe it'll break a little bit later
but if not then it's going to be kind of
astonishing if the democrats made this
accusation about their fellow elected
congress member either it's true in
which case people should go to jail for
literally ever or it is untrue in which
case you shouldn't be making accusations
of this magnitude without any evidence
to back them here were democrats
claiming that there was help for the
riders from inside the congress
i do believe there was some inside uh
assistance
yes somebody on the inside of those
buildings
were complicit in this there is no doubt
in my mind
that there were people inside the
capital
inside law enforcement perhaps even
other members
of the other side that may have been
involved in this there was a sense
that something was wrong and obviously
with the violence but there was a sense
that something was wrong
from the inside wow i mean if they can
actually
prove those claims then people should i
mean frankly that's treason right i mean
if you're actually aiding and abetting
a riot as an elected member of the
united states government that's that's
essentially treason
um but i i've not seen the evidence
presented to this point other than sort
of these vague suspicions and people
should not be throwing around
accusations with that unless they have
evidence to back it because that's
that's pretty extraordinary so all of
this is culminating
in the inauguration of joe biden which
will happen next week
and it appears the democrats have now
raised the ante on what they are going
to attempt to do
the economic reports right now are just
abysmal the the new economic reports
show that the economy is
really underperforming even what a lot
of folks
thought that it was going to do they
thought they were going to be like 800
000 new people out of jobs it's more
like a million
uh the numbers are really really bad
today uh and democrats are are seizing
the opportunity to talk about making big
big changes according
to peter cohen writing for roll call
says democrats plan a spending blowout
they've hinted tax increases will be
delayed until later this year at the
earliest
helping buoy investor optimism so they
are just going to delay the tax
increases
because they don't wish to stymie the
economy which should be the smart move
but they also wish to blow out the
spending top democrats are apparently
prepping trillions of dollars more
to goose disposable income help the
unemployed relief state and local
government budgets so they want to now
bail out the state and localities
for having spend like like drunken
sailors on shore leave
hypercharge the vaccine rollout build
out clean energy
housing broadband water transportation
infrastructure subsidized paid leave and
child care
and more according to russ sullivan
former staff director for the senate
finance
committee democrats who worked closely
with the obama administration on
stimulus healthcare and tax
biden and his team are not going to
raise taxes on anyone until the economy
is fully recovered
or at least more stable but it looks as
though they are going to be
pushing very very hard for extraordinary
spending
biden said on friday he wants additional
swift action on an economic aid package
including
1400 per person checks on top of the 600
that started going out
last week the price tag alone will be in
the trillions of dollars
biden said so more trillions of dollars
out the door some of us
who were fans of fiscal discipline and
didn't like the budgets that trump was
signing into law
even though we were on the republican
side of the aisle it turns out that
those of us in favor of fiscal
discipline
are still in favor of fiscal discipline
so some of us were actually consistent
on this issue
the democrats basically have budget
reconciliation that's pretty much it
they can use that twice this year
because congress never adopted a fiscal
2021 budget blueprint last year so
that's available until the end of
september
when congress adopts a budget resolution
which is no small feat in its own right
the document directs committees to draft
legislation hitting budgetary targets if
it's a deficit cut
they have to produce a minimum level of
savings if it's deficit increase they
can lose that amount and
no more and then they bundle that
together into a filibuster-proof package
but um expectations should be tempered
as well however democrats do have
some rather large plans here and that is
exacerbated by the fact
that bernie sanders is apparently going
to be cheering up the budget committee
which is
essentially a uh a republican nightmare
you have an
open socialist talking about heading up
the budget committee which is just
i mean good night good night grandma i
mean
it is bad news all the way around the
new york times reporting
that republicans have long feared the
prospect of sanders a self-described
democratic socialist taking the helm
of the powerful committee given his
embrace of bigger government and more
federal spending
that fear is about to become a reality
sanders will have a central role in
shaping and spear
and steering the democrats tax and
spending plans through a congress
that they control with the slimmest of
margins
he sanders says that he is going to be
as aggressive as humanly possible he
says underline the word aggressive
start out there so he's going to be
pushing tax healthcare
climate change and several other
domestic issues his role as budget
chairman will give him control over a
little known but incredibly powerful
congressional tool reconciliation
allowing congress to move some
legislation without gaining 60 votes so
look for the budget blowout to happen
immediately
again all politics eventually ends up
channeled into the into the legislative
process
and if bernie sanders is heading that up
it is bad news already so
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of the ben shapiro show
in the meantime
head on over to the michael knowles show
which is available right at this moment
michael is covering some uplifting news
from the supreme court worth noting i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
the house impeaches president trump
again aoc unwittingly offers
insight and conservatives score a win at
the supreme court check it out in the
michael knowles show